if my goal indigo it going into a
conversation is to improve my
relationship with you does that make me
some kind of some kind of a fake person
right oh I'm a fake person because I'm
just trying to trick Dave into liking me
it's like no actually I want us to win
yeah and by the way I you know this goes
back to the difference between
leadership and manipulation which I
talked about so if if my goal is to get
you to do something that's gonna benefit
me
yeah that's manipulation and it's wrong
if my goal in getting improving our
relationship is so that our team can do
better we can accomplish our mission and
both of those things by the way benefit
you well guess what that's called
it's called leadership so you know with
that you know how because some people on
the flip side of that whole spectrum is
like they'll do that but it's almost
like and I guess it's a question free so
you know like okay your voice coming to
America remember that that Joe Eddie
Murphy
so it was is where Eddie Murphy African
guy yeah and they're like princes or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel he
could even Arsenio Hall was also a
nephew in there but yes sir um so
anyways so someone tells them that he's
like hey you got to get in good with the
dad that's how you do it so he's like
okay he's gonna build this relationship
apparently he goes in and he'd like it's
like weird you know say essentially the
point is he forced it he tried to force
it so it didn't work so in real life how
that looks is like you ever get like I
don't know your friends like a real
estate agent or something any sending
you like handwritten notes like hey just
wondering how you don't you like Breyer
I don't even know you that good you know
it's like so you through obvious the one
who try to force a good relationship you
know and it almost makes you kind of
suspicious I mean nowadays this is sure
so it's almost like it's called a
brown-noser and people consume video if
you're a brown-noser that's that's
that's a good point yeah but there's a
dichotomy with everything if you go so
far that all I'm looking to do is please
Dave with this conversation there's no
tension at all there's no there's
there's nothing just be put being a
pushover well guess what happens with
his respect for me it's respect goes
down a little bit so I'm not talking
about you gotta be just a brown-noser at
all yeah yeah no no and then there's
that's YouTube but there's a nut and the
one I was thinking about her
but for some thinking about is like you
can tell that this person you're just
trying to build a relationship for me or
with me I don't know why I can suspect
why maybe you want my business or maybe
you want something you want something I
know and that's kind of at the forefront
so I mention this later in the book you
know how you just crush that I'll tell
you how you crush it when I'm talking to
Dave you know why I'm talking to Dave
you know why I want to build a
relationship because I care about Dave
yeah the number one thing for oh when
I'm talking to Dave Dave knows that you
know what I care about Dave if that's
the underlying if that's the underlying
principle on which we're that I'm doing
this is because I care about him he's
gonna know that yet that's
subconsciously subconsciously and maybe
sometimes you got to be a little bit
more proactive and make sure that you
know someone understands it like I mean
and it doesn't mean proactive by saying
hey Dave I really care about you that
doesn't work you can't just say it
yeah I've gotta prove by your actions
you got to show people like hey guess
what's more important than me you yeah
so when I'm talking to you and I'm
listening to you and I'm taking your
advice on board and I'm saying yeah you
know what let's go with your plan I'm
doing that because I want you to execute
your plan I want you to learn from your
plan I want to support your plan because
I care about you yeah that makes it
actually that that's good right there
that makes sense now so so it's almost
like actually it is where if I want to
build a relationship with Dave I'm not
gonna think okay let me focus on bill
let me actively build a relationship
just out of the blue or out of nothing
it's like it's more like that's almost
in a way secondary well the further the
primary thing is like do I need to talk
to Dave then yeah I'll talk to Dave but
while I do that the point is to build a
relationship with them I'm not gonna be
like I need to build a relationship with
Dave where's Dave let me call him up and
start trying to build a relationship
with him yeah so you're right and
there's there's a danger here that
you're you're someone's going to be in
court courage to force right there
impose good relationships on people
right so yeah that you got to be careful
atoms and and again
and actually here's the next line in
this book you are not building the
relationship so you can garner favor
from the boss know you were trying to
build a relationship so the boss trusts
you and will listen to you so you and
the team can more effectively accomplish
the mission yeah that's what you're
doing you want to accomplish the mission
which is good for everybody and then it
goes back and says for these reasons
choose your battle carefully because if
you remember this whole paragraph is
about like when do you actually approach
the boss when is it worth saying the
boss hey hey boss can you explain this
to me because I'm not sure that I
understand what you want to have happen
here if it's not worth that conversation
cuz not gonna be that big of a
difference mm-hmm just go with it you
know just just go with it but what I'm
saying is like I could see someone maybe
reading this I could see me reading
let's face it
I see me reading that and going to like
let's say I had a job hmm and I could
read that and I'd be like hey let me
build a relationship with chuckle and
then I'll just roll in kinda out of the
blue and be like hey cuz I'm building my
relationship so I can grow in a trust
that's what I'm doing right now so this
is what I'm gonna do hey joko did you
catch that that football game last night
and you're like what are you talking
about like you're acting weird
here's the deal if the premise that you
go on in on is you want to build a
relationship with me for your own
benefit the I'm gonna see right through
that so does anybody else if the premise
that you go in is because you care about
me and you're wondering if I saw the
football game because you know I like
football and you want to talk to me
about it and you care about me yeah
that's gonna shine through and I'm not
gonna think this other negative thing so
yes if you're a person that's walking
around you're gonna use the principles
in this book to benefit yourself
everyone's gonna see through it it
doesn't work and what's really cool and
this is all the like the closing of the
book is what we're getting to right now
is if you want to if you want to have a
successful run as a leader and you wanna
rise to the top the best possible way to
do that is to care about your team care
about the mission take care of them and
that will show through and eventually
you will get to the top if you're if
you're sitting there thinking hey I want
to get to the top so I'm ready to do
whatever it takes and step on people or
use people it's it's so obvious yeah
it's so obvious when someone's playing
in that game in
can barely even fake it you can't barely
even fake it like well I'm look I'm
gonna get to the top but I know I have
to be cool Dave my boss yeah so I'm
gonna manipulate here it's you and
here's the here's the really sad thing
if you're that person you think no one
can see it right hi everyone good see ya
that's kind of the point there where
like you got to be careful with that
kind stuff where like if if I'm trying
to build a relationship like brother can
see what you're doing you know spray
like cuz again this is more gotta be
careful with it here's how you be
careful with it if you're trying to do
this for yourself it's not gonna work if
you're trying to do this because you
care about the team it's gonna work and
and you're gonna win yeah you personally
are gonna win if you do this if you do
this because you want to win you're
gonna lose ya do this if you want to
take care of those people and you want
the team to win and you want them to
accomplish the mission so they can
elevate yeah it will work yeah let's do
huh if I want to win if you're if you're
a young leader right now listening to
this conversation and thinking about how
you can build a relationship and the
power of the relationship with your
people actually those individual how you
interact with that individual person
isn't the biggest thing because what
those people in your team are doing is
watching you
so maybe jakka comes out and wants to
build a relationship with me and okay
I'm trying to figure out as the
authentic or genuine what I actually get
to do is watch Jaco with the other 10
dudes on the team and over time if Jocko
is just how he is and he believes in
that and that actually he's gonna treat
everybody the same way and it's not
gonna be what he does or or says to me
that gets me to buy off that he's on
board of this as I'm gonna see him in
all the other and everything else that
he does I'm gonna come to the conclusion
like - this is legit that guy that guy -
that guy cares but everybody else being
successful and then those are gonna need
you at times and there you will have
opportunities to build relationships but
the authenticity isn't just what do I
say to echo to get echo to like me or
every favor with echo because actually
what you're doing to your leader is
you're watching everything that are
doing and the reason being fake about it
doesn't work isn't because I just see it
with me is
you do with everybody else that's why
it's so obvious because you're out there
trying to figure how to play the game of
all these ten different people and if
you're if you're faking it it it's gonna
it's gonna be completely obvious not
because of how you and I interact so the
thing that actually has to start with if
you've now put put in charge of a team
or a leader go back and read that second
platoon commander from chaco second
platoon he didn't walk in and go I'm
honored to lead you to count you as
people that worked for me on my team he
just said I'm happy to be part of this
and I'm happy to help make this team win
that's it you don't need to elevate the
statute everybody knows who the bosses
the chain of command is understood
everybody's got that hierarchy what you
actually need to do is look for ways to
break down those barriers and just have
them recognize all this guy cares about
is us winning that's all he cares about
and by behavior after behavior after
behavior eventually either doing it or
you're not and if you're doing it people
gonna get on board if you're not you're
going to fail no matter what you do and
people are gonna see that a mile away oh
yeah smell it on you mm-hm